so so anyway look
um
well what you were saying it's you know
the
lydia and i were talking about this too
which is
one of the
weirdest things that happened
was
i could have made money and needed money
and i didn't want to be a you know
center-right version of the pretentious
liberal that i was because that's what
got me in trouble it was being a
self-righteous loud liberal then i have
an affair and they go hahaha you're not
perfect you know that was the story any
comic on stage who did what i did who
talked about it um especially talked
about it with like regret like yeah i
wish i didn't do it it was awful um you
know no one's getting in trouble for
that but so you you this is what you got
canceled over on the left yeah yeah yeah
and so but
in the feminist world a consensual
affair got called sexual misconduct
consensual one nice dance got called
predatory behavior and i was like
it's insane remember aziz ansari yeah he
had a bad date and she was like it was a
salt and he was like whoa yeah the
woodward and bernstein reporting of
babe.net is that the article you were
talking it was literally called babe.net
there was like no fact checking i mean
there was a line in the jezebel article
written about me where it said a girl a
girl that i slept with sorry a woman um
that i slept with um
literally in the article said something
along the lines of it was the safest i
felt with a man something saying that
when i'm with women i treat them well
and then
said uh but a week later he called me a
road f
on his podcast and then jezebel in
parentheses said jezebel could not find
that quote and it's like right because
i'm not talking about smashing road poon
on my feminist podcast with my wife you
psychopaths but they still printed that
and that was enough and that headline
will still come up when people are
looking for me i mean i've had to have
so many people don't think about what
cancellations like i've lost tons of
gigs still this is eight years ago i am
a literally different man um
every relationship i've had uh try
explaining to elderly conservative
parents of your girlfriend what the
metoo movement is or what an open
relationship like there's just weird
stuff that will haunt you always but i i
do feel like if you're you're meeting
your girlfriend's conservative parents
for the first time and you want to
explain to them cancellation you can be
like a bunch of libs were lying about
trying to cancel me and they'll be like
we got you these feminists yeah i mean
yeah yeah you know what that is probably
the move i should do conservatives not
ask enough questions
what do you mean i'm giving you a hard
time cause you're like yeah no i got
cancelled by a bunch of liberals they're
like oh nice not like for what what
happened no no they're gonna say i get
it yeah yeah they're gonna say oh i know
exactly what that would be like let me
bang your daughter and we'll drink these
liberal tears together
because if you're like if you google
search me there's some bad things that
come up they're gonna go
but if you say a bunch of feminists got
mad and started lying about me they'll
be like we hear your brother yeah
they're going to be like you poor man
and then they're going to the father's
going to be like i approve of this
relationship you know what that's my
go-to excuse for anything i do wrong
ever again like dude a bunch of feminist
lied about me i don't know i'm sorry but
we have a recording of you saying that
was from feminist recordings
even with my family uh my mom's like
your your your brother said that you did
this as a bunch of feminists lying about
don't even worry about it don't worry
about like you're at a trump rally and
you fart and some woman calls you out
like it's much feminist she's she's a
feminist and they're like oh she's lying
yes yeah you didn't say you didn't see
antifa run by fart and then you jump
into the bushes it was literally an
anti-super soldier
so
uh before the show you were asking me
like if i had a moment where i moved or
anything like that yeah and i was i was
saying like i'm in i'm i'm in
essentially the exact same place i've
always been except for like gun control
right because i was moderate on gun
control now i'm basically two-way
absolutist then i've even argued the
constitution guarantees the right of an
individual to have nuclear weapons you
want to change it i'm not saying that it
should be that way i'm saying people had
cannons and and and uh frigates and
private tears and all that stuff uh so
for me
i didn't i didn't change but the issue
is conservatives didn't change either
everybody changed a little bit everybody
moved a little bit to the left actually
you can you can look at data from the
from the new york times the
conservatives seem way cooler with like
gay people right like trump unfurled an
lgbt flag on stage like the rnc or
something did he do it gaily though
i would have been the flex but he made
he made a point about how you know the
the guy who uh you know shot the
nightclub he was like he's killing our
people and right and they clapped for it
they're like yes like that's wrong
and so there there were a lot of uh
changes that happened uh trump being
okay with gay marriage was it was uh
you know how a lot of people were like
okay like this is this is this is obama
and clinton weren't okay with it right
right right it got passed because biden
like slipped up on the view right or
something like that so so i'm watching
this uh this video from rap news rap
news number six
and uh
pro free speech
pro julian assange and i'm like all of
these positions right now if you watch
that you'd be a trump supporter and this
was back during occupy was like
pre-occupy wall street when they
actually the rap news guys filmed at
occupy wall street and i'm in the video
as part of a group with anonymous and
we're like yelling stuff because when i
found out that they were making the
video i i i saw them their faces started
spitting bars i know i was like let me
let me in like dude i love this stuff
so i'm just like an extra in it yeah as
we're all like chanting or whatever
but if you follow them if you believed
in what they believed back then you
would be a trump supporter today right
well i can't remember who made this
point but it was one of our guests and
they said do you think anyone who was in
a coma for 10 years and then woke up
today would go oh my gosh things have
gotten so far to the right like do you
think they'd read the newspaper and see
current events and go oh my goodness
this country's so conservative now i i
have uh
i'll try and keep as much information
you know private as possible but there
are certain individuals of moderate uh
prominence
who were let's just say uh indisposed
for a few years during the trump
administration when they came out
they were they were politically homeless
and confused because the left was not
the left anymore
so uh i used to hang out with a ton of
people in the hacker community
uh back preoccupy wall street can they
help my up my google search if they're
listening to this i mean yes they can
you guys shoot me a dm please these are
these are like reputation management
firms these days and all this stuff so
my hacker friends were pro free speech
pro edgy comedy
they were very very into super offensive
internet posts trolling
um goatsy stuff shock content lemon
party all those really awful things
don't let your kids go look up don't do
it
something happened
tell the kids about it and then tell
them don't look so there are there are
certain people who they'll pay the price
for that
oh i don't even know what the certain
hackers who end up going to prison yeah
with a limited access to news and and
the
internet culture yeah
they come out
and then all of a sudden they're like
all right where's the left and they're
like we don't like free speech anymore
and they're like what yeah and like all
the things you used to say and do that
we were friends with you for if you do
now we will punish you i mean
louis j gomez the legion of skanks guys
we're called proud boys louis j gomez
who is puerto rican they're some of the
funniest comedians in the world and i
did shows to them a couple weeks ago
and their audience is if you just follow
twitter you would assume it's an
audience of nazis and their audience is
diverse they are sweet um they just like
good comedy but now yeah your friends
get out of jail and ben shapiro is the
only one defending dave chappelle where
the right has suddenly taken on dave
chappelle and
the left is it's just again isolating
and alienating comedy fans now i will
say
on the other side and i think this
doesn't have to do with left or right
it's just tribalism in general
i remember something that really
disappointed me was i went on a bunch of
right-wing shows and i stayed liberal
you know i went on glenn beck's it was
great we disagreed with some stuff but i
got to talk about palestine and glenn
beck show that's dope and we mainly
talked about tribalism
and i did a bunch of other right-wing
shows
and again you're a grifter if i go on a
right-wing show and i start saying
things i don't believe in for money
right if i go on glenn becks i'm like
yeah build a wall and it's just stuff i
don't believe in but i was still myself
so i get like hundreds of new followers
and a bunch of people saying
the equivalent of
i don't agree with you but i like that
you're trying to bring people together
blah blah then george floyd gets killed
and i start posting
a bunch of don't kill black people
nothing crazy not old preachy jaime just
don't kill black people
and which again even trump and pence
ended up saying that that was bad right
and i remember people
even on my instagram which is usually
less of a cesspool than twitter we're
like oh looks like feminist cuck jaime's
back here we go with lib stuff and the
fact that i got cancelled
by some fake feminists
implies that i have to be pro
george floyd being killed like that's
why i think tribalism is the problem
absolutely you know what i mean and
right now the left is doing the worst on
the right but it still happens on both
sides we're don't don't pretend you are
above my politics and think i'm a good
guy and
just while i can be used as a prop of
course where you can just point to me
and be like oh look at that guy he's
anti-woke he got screwed over by
whatever i'm like i don't want to be
anyone's prop i can still have these
thoughts that sometimes conservatives
will disagree with sometimes liberals
will disagree with that's why i think
it's the rule for the left the exception
for the right in terms of
uh that animosity the left is very
tribal if you deviate on one thing boom
your right wing that's crazy the right
you'll certainly have people you know
people posted me and stuff and all the
time as well
um
but for the most part
you're
they're not gonna they might yell at you
but that's about it they're not gonna
call your boss yeah do you think a lot
of it's just twitter in general
because when i meet liberal people at
the gym or on a date or conservative
people
i think actually more people than we
think feel the exact same way we're
talking you just get the lunatics on
both sides on twitter no they're just
trying to get into audio because they
work for veritas damn it i knew i did it
uh but we met organically no no
there's the right with lunatics aren't
on on twitter they're all banned
well that's actually a good point you're
seeing the sanitized conservative
movement on twitter and you're seeing
the fringe of the left on twitter so
this was bad for democrats and i i
warned about this like three four years
ago
i put it this way
you see two little boys with a with an
adult woman and she's got two little
boys with her one's just drenched in
dirt and chocolate and ice cream and
he's all messy looking the other kid is
perfect and clean with a smile on his
face
and
from the outset you say
okay that kid is a disaster he's messy
and that other kid is clean and
responsible
but the reality is the mother just
doesn't let the clean kid have ice cream
ugh
so the kid who's allowed to have ice
cream makes a mess and the kid wasn't
allowed to have it doesn't have the
opportunity to make a mess when twitter
started suspending bad voices or voices
they thought were bad on the right they
were making it so that the most
prominent conservative people on twitter
were ben shapiro you know a a practical
logical moderate conservative guy you're
or i should say uh traditional
conservative
and then the left is antifa saying burn
it down and threatening death so a
regular person goes on and says oh
that's a little too much
this
this allows twitter allowing the left to
say and do crazy things radicalizes
people it it generates it charges up the
engine but people on the right are like
i don't want to get banned so i'm not
going to say that right it's actually
making people on the right try and dress
up and get clean and the left is running
amok smashing windows and looking stupid
which is so funny because whenever my
argument for
when people would equate the extremes on
both sides because i was like oh what
the left wants you to have like too much
health care or wants to end all the war
but yeah when you start advocating
violence it's like well no that's that's
who we're talking about exactly and so
this is an argument that people on the
far left are still making so i saw this
the other day when the far left was
referred to there were all sorts of
lefties going oh what does far left mean
they really want universal health care
and i was like dude the positions you're
describing all apply to tim poole but
he's called far right he's like well
obviously we're talking about the far
left we're talking a lot about the
social issues yeah i mean policy wise
i think
i would not compare universal health
care to bombing iraq and afghanistan but
then again you have democrats who are
also yeah droning every democrat voted
to fund one of the largest war packages
in history with ukraine the rest
it's like what six times what anyone
else in europe has paid we put in 54
billion dollars
every democrat even the squad
so you know what man
that that is
it's funny when we have a debate or
argument with you know matt on abortion
and i'm like this has never been a
really big issue for me because for one
i'm not a woman i'm not a a legal moral
or theological scholar i mean it's i i
you know i had a conversation with glenn
beck and ultimately ultimately i ended
with like man i really just don't know i
just feel like there's a barrier for me
and i i can't really i don't i don't
know the answer because you're good and
like that should be the answer but war
this one's always been very clear-cut
for me and i know a decent amount about
what we do why we do it why we want to
enforce the petro dollar i bring up all
the time the cutter turkey pipeline gas
problem all this stuff and i'm like it
is bad that we are doing these things if
you can go from being uh you're like i'm
on the left and and i'm like okay and
you're the anti-war party and then you
vote for joe biden right i'm going to
look at you and say huh yep and then
when joe biden's like come on give me
the biggest war package in history
you're like okay i'm like he's folksy
progressives are pro-war yeah
progressives are pro-war liberals are
pro-war democrats are pro-war and half
the republicans are pro-i mean i
discovered this i got in a lot of
trouble the one time and only time i
went on the conan o'brien show because i
talked all about drone strikes but i did
not talk all about drone strikes under
bush bush is when i started talking
about war but obama was still using
drones so it was under obama and the uh
it was me and kobe bryant were the only
other guests so not exactly like my
audience tuning in and if you watch the
clip the clip's probably still on
youtube it goes well with the audience
but i was told it was the most
complaints they've gotten and
that's why my belief has always been
just principles over party that's it
it's if you're anti-war be anti-war
under bush be anti-war under obama yes
be anti-war under trump be anti-war
under bud it's
that simple but the fact that there's
such cognitive dissonance and not only
will suddenly they be pro-war
but then they're just getting defensive
and they're acting like you're a monster
for criticizing biden or that susan
sarandon's the reason roe v wade's being
overturned it's absolute insane thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there
you